along with the release of an
action-packed three cool we're bringing
you a new season of an adventure drama
the premiere of a live-action manga
classic the 14th and final season of an
adult animated hit and a young adult
animated spin-off series that's just
getting started it's all coming up on
this week's what to watch
nine seconds
adding itself into theaters is The
Equalizer 3 because Denzel just can't be
stopped of course if there's a third
installment of something that's a good
sign meaning the previous two which also
starred Denzel Washington and were
directed by Antoine Fuqua were really
something and indeed they were the first
film is fresh on the Tomato Meter while
both one and two boast strong audience
scores so it's not surprising that they
both also performed quite well at the
box office and while the success of the
previous two is one reason to put
yourself in this equation another would
be that number three offers up a brand
new location and a new set of
circumstances in it Denzel's Robert
McCall finds himself serving Justice in
southern Italy where he ends up jumping
in to take on some crime bosses to help
the locals out of a tough situation the
third reason to consider The Equalizer 3
is that this franchise clearly isn't
going anywhere as you might remember the
films are Loosely based on the 1980s TV
series while a new series yet another
reboot of the original show premiered on
CBS in 2021 starring Queen Latifah and
is still going strong
we didn't defeat The Dark One
we set him free
[Music]
clocking in for a second season on Prime
is the adventure drama series The Wheel
of Time season 2 was announced before
the first one even premiered and that
confidence paid off with a certified
fresh first season which critics said
succeeds admirably in making Robert
Jordan's epic approachable for the
uninitiated and speaking of Jordan the
second reason to give this one a spin is
that it is based on his popular book
series published between 1990 and 2013
with season 2 combining elements from
books two and three if you know you know
and because some fun facts also make
good reasons to watch a show it's worth
noting that showrunner Rafe Judkins who
developed the series for Prime appeared
as a contestant on the 11th season of
Survivor in Guatemala the tribe has
spoken there's no one misses with my
friends
hitting Netflix this week is the new
series one piece this is a live Act
action adaptation of the ongoing 1997
Japanese manga series of the same name
by aichiro Oda which is the first and
biggest reason to check this one out the
second reason is that this series which
will focus on the East blue Saga and
intro the members of the straw hat
Pirates hopes to be an accessible
Pathway to the Epic and vast world
that has been created for one piece and
thirdly the one and only Ian McShane is
providing the narration for the series
which frankly should be mandatory for
pretty much all shows ever
fresh young agent anymore
[Music]
dozens of knife and projectile wounds
your liver is hanging on by a thread how
many concussions have you had
it's not a concussion if you remember it
arriving for its 14th season is The
Animated FX series Archer and not only
is it season 14 for this series it is
also the last so how will it all end
what a great reason to give this season
a watch another reason is that not only
has the show won for prime time Emmy
Awards and four Critics Choice Awards
the 11 previous Seasons that have enough
reviews are all fresh which is good
enough for a 90 Tomato Meter average and
fear not fans of the show because with
various companion books having been
published and a nationwide tour with
actors reimagining scenes from the show
clearly Archer has found a place in
popular culture and that's reason enough
to finish strong with season 14. action
stuff
found you now that is the party I don't
want to miss
[Music]
and premiering on Max is the why a
animated series Adventure Time Fiona and
Cake Cake makes everything better this
is the third Series in the franchise and
is a spin-off of the Cartoon Network
show Adventure Time which is a great
first reason to go on this adventure
another would be that the idea for the
gender swapped main characters Fiona and
Cake began has some drawings that were
posted to social media early in the
show's run which eventually turned into
real characters in an episode and now
they're getting their own show what a
journey and fans will be happy to know
that this spin-off is in good hands with
executive producer Adam Muto who was
previously showrunner for Adventure Time
toward the end of its run and also
oversaw production of the distant Land
Special that came out in 2020. so the
dude knows what's up is all I'm saying
okay that's it five picks to help you
keep your viewing calendar in one piece
be sure to let us and your fellow
viewers know in the comments what you
did check out whether it was on this
list or not remember to check out
rottentomatoes.com for the latest
updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large that's all
for today fresh family until next week
stay fresh